en plein après midi quartier chomedey à
laval hier deux fillettes tente
d'attraper de chatons sous une voiture
quand un véhicule suspect noire
s'approche à quelques mètres d'elle pour
ouvrir le feu sur un individu
de l'autre côté de la rue l'homme
atteint à la cuisse temps de trouver
refuge sous le regard
[Musique]
moi j'étais ici en train de prendre du
soleil mais j'avais mes écouteurs j'ai
entendu papa pas embrasser des choses
qui arrivent que men on va toujours où
l'épreuve franchement pas bien du tout
parce que ça risque la vie du monde et
puis il y avait deux filles les deux
filles de madame qui étaient là au moins
quatre laval s'est rendu le far west
tout le quartier chaud bd est devenue le
théâtre de la violence armée à laval
depuis dimanche trois fusillades ont
fait un mort puis un blessé hier après
midi le service de police dit avoir
déployé des effectifs sur le terrain
pour freiner ces événements qui
ébranlent la population lavalloise je
peux vous dire que mes enquêteurs depuis
trois jours un non port et elle m'a
endormi si vous me prêtez l'expression
ils travaillent sans relâche pour pour
solutionner sicules la tentative de
meurtre d'hier porte la marque des gangs
de rue d'abord le véhicule du tireur
suit discrètement celui de sa cible puis
lors d'un deuxième passage il en profite
pour repéré l'individu qu'il doit
abattre le tireur aura à peine le temps
d'ouvrir le feu alors que son conducteur
lui aura déjà enfoncé l'accélérateur
pour prendre la fuite sa vie sur le
territoire on a plusieurs gangs de rue
certaines d'entre elles ont des conflits
non seulement entré là à laval mais on
dit conscient avec d'autres gangs de
montréal ces fusillades à laval ont
alimenté le débat à l'assemblée
nationale la stratégie 100 ans porte ses
fruits ya deux semaines sur un briefing
de suivi avec tous les corps de police
notamment le directeur de laval qui me
dit qu'ils sont très très actif sur le
terrain entre temps les citoyens et
redoute que la saison estivale
s'accompagne d'une flambée de violences
dans leur quartier ici pascal robidas
radio canada à laval